also ich bin hier hingekommen um
irgendwie ein signal zu setzen für
toleranz leben und auch weltoffenheit
weil es einerseits um ein schreckliches
ereignis was da geschehen ist was aber
leider auch politisch instrumentalisiert
wird von rechter seite und da möchte ich
für gegner ein stehen und sagen dass
helfen spaß
ich arbeite seit über viereinhalb jahren
mit flüchtlingen zusammen unter lebe
einfach in der täglichen arbeit
das einfach ganz normale menschen sind
wie du und ich und es gibt halt auch bei
ganz normalen menschen arschlöcher das
muss man einfach so in der deutlichkeit
sagen und jetzt dieser fall es war eben
ein arschloch und das ist ein tragischer
fall
und da ist halt unser tiefes mitgefühl
aus
die wollen sich hier integrieren das
erlebnis immer wieder in meiner arbeit
und dann ist es schade wenn einer ein
mensch oder ein paar wenige andere dann
die ganze gruppe alles kaputt machen die
integration
ich bin eine der initiatoren von der
initiative kandel ist überall
wir sind hierher gekommen um den
menschen zu zeigen dass es parallelen
gibt zwischen verschiedenen fällen und
die fälle ähneln sich das heißt wenn man
für schutz und sicherheit sorgen will
muss man irgendwann auch an die ursache
gehen
man darf nicht tolerant sein aus
bequemlichkeit wenn man tolerant aus
überzeugung ist dann ist es in ordnung
aber man darf nicht einfach die fakten
leugnen oder sich nicht informieren und
hier dass einer der toleranz vor sich
her tragen denn das ist eigentlich nur
dummheit
familie